bonjour et bienvenue aujourd'hui je suis
en direct du château de chenonceaux pour
vous parler du fait que le seul axe hier
vers le haut et aucun lien entre le lieu
est thème de la vidéo
si je fais cette vidéo c'est pour vous
narrer mes difficultés à expliquer aux
gens ou en coin que les gens que c'est
trop cool de penser que cela que servent
et avant de commencer j'aimerais
vraiment insisté le fait que pour moi ce
qui est intéressant ce qui est important
c'est que ces d'amorcer toute une
réflexion sur le fait que ce avec
cervélo c'est ce qui a conduit en
italien créé toute une théorie de la
relativité générale et plus que ça c'est
le plus important derrière cette
réflexion magique à mon sens le soleil
servir le sait que c'est une idée
incroyablement heureuse c'est l'idée la
plus heureuse einstein et âme à titre
personnel c'est aussi une idée qui m'a
rendu incroyablement heureux pendant
pendant des mois qu'elle prend mais moi
je réfléchissais à cette idée mais c'est
juste génial que tout ce temps on va
continuer s'explique par le fait que les
seuls accès vers l'autre c'est c'est
trop beaucoup et je pense que n'importe
qui est capable d'apprécier cela je
pense que n'importe qui y compris des
enfants très jeunes
et puis des personnes beaucoup plus âgés
ont arrêté à physique depuis des
décennies tout le monde peut apprécier
le fait que le sol accélère vers l'eau
il suffit juste de prendre le temps
vraiment d'y réfléchir et c'est pas un
truc qui se fait comme ça en trente
secondes pour vraiment comprendre cette
idée toute la beauté de cette idée il
faut réfléchir quotidiennement et je
trouve qu'il ya pas grand chose de mieux
dans toutes les sciences pour susciter
l'amour de la réflexion que cette idée
selon laquelle le sol accélère vers le
haut
comment ces assises nationales et pc
avait dit de ne plus oser rose de sa vie
c'est vraiment je pense une idée et si
on prend vraiment le temps d'y réfléchir
qui peut être l'idée qui va être
déclenchée en amour pour la réflexion
donc c'est pour ça que je trouve ça très
important que tous y pensent pense au
fait que le seul accès sauf qui est la
difficulté que j'ai pas mal rencontré
vis-à-vis de cela c'est que beaucoup de
gens refusent de même penser une idée
que le sol accéléré vers le haut et y
compris bon et déjà dans mes
commentaires et y compris dans des
groupes de discussions scientifiques sur
facebook
beaucoup de gens ont été extrêmement
durs avec moi on va dire limite moi je
m'en fous je suis capable de prendre
brûlé beaucoup les critiques mais qui
sont mis vraiment à discréditer et a
surtout encouragé les autres gens de ne
pas réfléchir au fait que le seul accès
revalo de juste rejeté cette idée d'un
seuil d'un coup d'un seul ça ça ça va ça
m'embête beaucoup puisque ça va
complètement à l'opposé de ce que j'ai
envie que vous fassiez en regardant mes
vidéos savoir réfléchir en fait que ça
avec cervélo des gens qui essayent de
couper votre réflexion sur le fait qu
accélérer l'accès vers le haut je pense
qu'ils desservent énormément à cause des
sciences à savoir cet amour pour la
réflexion alors ceci dit je comprends
que ce soit extrêmement difficile de
penser que ce le seul accès revers loge
je conçois complètement qu'il se soit
une idée soit très difficile à accepter
et la raison pour laquelle c'est
difficile c'est que il n'y a pas
beaucoup de très bons arguments que je
peux vous sortir en t'attendant sur
facebook ou dans mes commentaires pour
vous convaincre du fait que le soleil
c'est l'art vers le haut le meilleur
argument que j'ai c'est l'argument
d'autorité c'est l'argument de
essentiellement mon autorité je veux
dire que bon bah je suis quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup d'eau diplôme beaucoup réfléchi
aux maths physique qui a ce fait des
années que je réfléchisse relativité
générale que j'adore ça je vais beaucoup
travailler je comprends les danseurs
d'ailleurs la vidéo que j'ai fait sur
les danseurs de leur activité général a
clairement beaucoup aidé à me faire
gagner en crédibilité
mes amis qui me connaissent quand je
leur dise que le sol accélère vers le
haut ils savent que c'est pas débile ce
qu'investit celle que ça vaut le coup
moins utilisé avec les six même si en
général nous ne crois pas tout de suite
au moins ils vont pas rejeter l'idée en
bloc ces arguments de l'autorité elle
est super importante et comme les gens
qui ne me connaissent pas nous ne
considérons pas comme une autorité
ils me demandent souvent des sources et
alors il se trouve qu'il ya des sources
terme en des gens regrette comme brian
green gables de people time
les chartes ier ou encore david au havre
sur son site avant tout ces gens là ont
des thèses en physique théorique et tous
ces gens là ont affirmé que le seul
accès à l'eau je suis pas le seul à dire
cela job de rêve de gosse ouais ouais
n est ce pas le truc c'est que le
référentiel simple c'est pas des
financiers le galiléen dont vous avez
l'habitude c'est pas un référentiel de
laboratoire
c'est celui en train de tomber nous
envie de tomber on a envie d'être un
étrange chute libre on a envie d'avancer
francine simple il va non le solde en
empêche le sol contre continuellement
mme accélère vers le haut imaginez une
plus une en fait c'est ça y est plus
d'observateurs ruche d'être entouré de
gens en train de tomber de temps sont
issus rex qu'on saute et de la nôtre qui
s'occupe de la fin de semaine par tous
en train de couler pour eux la musique
elle est simple pour eux et nos
centrales sont en gravitation
donc quand il veut faire les
traumatismes qu'ils font les compagnies
centralisation se faisait appeler vous
êtes là dans un référentiel différents
vous aimeraient bien être à leur place
mais vous pouvez pas vous êtes en train
d'être remonté par rapport à la si vous
pouviez vous m du point de vue de tous
les gens qui sont en train de tomber
s'ils sont tous sauvés de la motor va t
il se verrait tous immobiles des uns par
rapport aux autres et ils vous irez vous
filer vers le haut avec une accélération
- g c'est fou l'intrus dans l'histoire
la danse est dans cette pièce l'intrus
c'est nous qui sommes mobiles par
rapport au sol c'est pas une situation
naturelle
c'est vrai que je vais vous lire
rapidement un extrait du blog de son
site ou nantes
pour bien comprendre le changement de
perspectives considérées vous en train
de tomber d'un avion sans parachute
du point de vue de la relativité
générale vous ne subissez aucune force
vous vous contentez de suivre la
courbure de l'espace temps
vous suivez votre trajectoire géodésique
normal votre accélération au sens de la
relativité générale est nul
maintenant imaginez vous allonger dans
votre lit vous êtes dans un champ de
gravité pourtant vous ne tombez pas en
chute libre n'êtes donc pas dans la
trajectoire géodésique qui suit la
courbure de l'espace non en effet vous
subissez une force qui vous empêchent de
suivre cette trajectoire la force de
réaction de votre lit du point de vue de
la théorie de la relativité générale si
vous êtes statique dans un champ de
gravité vous subissez une accélaration
bonne nouvelle même si vous êtes affalé
immobile dans votre canapé vous êtes en
train d'accélérer
ceci dit beaucoup de gens m'ont critiqué
en disant que je n'étais pas capable de
sortir d'articles scientifiques de
recherche par exemple qui disent que le
sol accélère vers le remit en effet je
ne suis pas capable parce que je ne
connais pas de source
académique qui a 10 que le sol accélère
barlow quoique certains cours d'eau la
cité général mais ça qui à part ça
personne ne dit que très peu de gens que
j'ai trouvé très peu de sources qui
disent que le sol accélère vers le haut
peu la guerre des soir c'est la guerre
d'histoire se perd carrément et tout ce
que je peux faire
par rapport à cette absence de source
c'est regrettable le fait que
d'autres physiciens plus établis n'est
pas ne dise pas plus souvent que le sol
accélère vers le haut je pense qu'ils
devraient le dire et du coup vous pouvez
vous demander si moi je n'ai pas de
sources comment est ce que moi je pense
que le seul accès vers le haut et en
fait c'est pas du tout lié aux sourds et
ben faut savoir quand même cas pas que
l'argument d'autorité comme dans la vie
et qu'il ya d'autres façons de savoir
des choses en particulier il ya deux
autres sorte de raisonnement que juste
croire en des sources
le premier est l'argument inductif que
deuxième l'argument déductif l'argument
inductif il est important parce que
c'est l'argument des sciences donc on
fait des sciences ont fait de la
recherche scientifique surtout on fait
constamment de l'ain du ctif c'est à
dire on observe des phénomènes on essaie
d'expliquer le nu est possible et quand
on trouve une bonne façon d'expliquer
tout plein de phénomènes
on commence à être convaincu par ce
qu'on raconte et ça c'est l'argument
keynes bien sûr à utiliser einstein en
1905 quand il eu cette idée
s'il a été persuadé que le seul accès
vers le haut c'est pas parce que c'est
pas parce qu'il l'avait vu quelque part
n'est pas de sources mais c'est parce
que ça a expliqué super bien certains
trucs qui était assez étrange dans la
théorie newtonienne notamment le fait
que lorsque vous êtes en chute libre
vous ne sentez pas votre poids et que
les choses qui tombent avec vous semble
flotter par rapport à vous donc vous
semblez en apesanteur par rapport à ceux
qui tombent avec do c'est ce que j'ai
pas mal d'imagés avec l'idée de
l'astronaute et plus globalement
l'épisode 17 c'est ça c'est un argument
complètement inductif pour vous
convaincre que le sol accélère vers le
haut
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus intéressant à
mon sens c'est ses rangs le génie d'un
instant il en fait c'est ce qui m'a
rendu heureux c'est l'argument inductif
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus intéressant
cet argument inductif donc c'est ce que
j'ai mis le plus en avant dans les
vidéos cndd soir mais cet argument
inductif il n'est pas convaincant c'est
c'est l'argument de la recherche
scientifique conduit à faire des
spéculations intelligente mais ça reste
souvent spéculatifs et j'ai pas été
convaincus totalement en tout cas par
ses réflexions d'einstein
elles ont été très séduisante pas mal
séduit même pas complètement convaincu
sur le fait que ça l'accélère vers le
haut mais en fait si j'ai été convaincu
la première fois que le seul accès vers
le haut tout seul je sens le liard nulle
part
c'est avec un argument déductive qui par
des équations de la relativité générale
et en particulier de la métrique de
déchoir schild qui dit que les
géodésique à travers l'espace temps
doivent se rapprocher de la masse
centrale
surtout si réunion leur donne pas de
vitesse initiale par rapport à cette
masse initiale d'évitement sur terre ici
bon on a une vitesse de rotation par
rapport au centre de la terre mais qui
est très faible et du coup on devrait se
rapprocher du centre de la terre
c'est grossièrement la gravité peut
aller habiter ou la courbure de l'espace
temps dans la qualité générale c'est un
truc qui a tendance à rapprocher les
objets massifs les uns des autres
en tout cas en l'absence d'énergie noire
et du coup comme nous on se rapproche
pas du centre de la terre c'est qu'on ne
suis pas une je désire on dévie de notre
géodésique mais ça ça correspond à une
accélération et donc des équations de
ratifier général on déduit le fait qu'
on ne sut pas géodésique et que le sol
accélère vers le haut vers l'argument
est implacable c'est un théorème
mathématique et dire ce que j'ai fait
c'est supposer que les hypothèses de la
relativité générale et les bras et dans
le cadre de cette relativité générale du
coup d'en déduire
prouve que on explique que le sol
accélère vers le haut et ça c'est
l'argument ultime c'est l'argument
ultime dans le cadre de la relativité
générale du coup le seul accès revendre
au point barre c'est comme ça que j'ai
été convaincu ceci dit l'argument des
objectifs même si dans ce cas j'ai quand
même vraiment confiance en argument en
général il suffit pas pour être qu il me
suffit pas pour être parfaitement
convaincue de quelques quoi que ce soit
parce que j'ai très bien pu le faire une
erreur de raisonnement déductif c'est
toujours possible et dans ce cas c'est
vraiment la combinaison des trois qui
fait que tu me fais dire aujourd'hui que
il ya aucun doute en jeu le seul accès
vers le haut c'est comment combiner
trois ça ne fait aucun doute
là où le bât blesse c'est que cet
argument est compliqué tout comme
l'argument inductif est compliqué tous
ces arguments il faut des heures
vraiment pour les pour les déroulé pour
comprendre tout ce qu'il ya derrière
déjà avoir des jours voire des mois de
travail et du coup il est hors de
question que je lui dis ses arguments
dans des commentaires facebook ou dans
les commentaires de
youtube va me suis retrouvé confronté à
des commentaires facebook youtube qui
disent ah maintenant on le croyait pas a
été de penser à ça le sol et les fixes
tout ça quoi utiliser l'analogie de la
toile et marc reviens moi je ne peux pas
développer tous les arguments déductif
et inductif parce qu'ils sont juste trop
long et en plus l'immédiateté notamment
de ce qui se passe sur facebook fait que
les gens prennent pas le temps de la
réflexion donc ça ça ça ne sert à rien
de sortir les arguments inductif ou
déductif pour justifier le fait que le
seul accès vers le haut tout ce que je
peux faire à céüse pointé vers d'autres
se lancer et comme on a vu que les
sources et finalement n'était pas
parfaite assez défaillante
je suis à cours d'arguments je suis à
court d'arguments je ne sais pas comment
pousser les gens à entamer une réflexion
sur le fait que le sort excellent vers
l'eau je suis déjà renoué avec ses
mailles forces afin de ne pas trop
donner d'avis personnel ici c'est plus
un constat ou un partage de mes
difficultés à pousser les gens à
réfléchir en général et en particulier
sur le fait que ça l'accélère vers le
haut et en particulier comment lutter
contre ces gens qui disent qu'ils qui
nie complètement en bloc tout ce que je
raconte et qui pousse les autres à ne
pas entamer de réflexion sur le fait que
le seul accès si vous avez des idées sur
comment mieux pousser les gens à débuter
cette réflexion qui encore une fois est
géniale à mon sens c'est ce qui est
typiquement le genre de réflexion qui
peut faire aimer les sciences tissot
télé en particulier fait rimer réfléchir
si vous avez des idées quand et comment
y arriver
n'hésitez pas à les mettre dans les
commentaires